Jim we've managed to sneak into the
premises of
[Music]
[Applause]
reign supreme there's no sense of morals
anywhere here Jim if there was then
surely we wouldn't know that there was
police justice running in cities home
[Music]
Jim I've got eyes on maybe not though
and we can't be sure if anything
entirely possible Jim that this is the
detective who is gathering clues been
doing some gathering of our own take for
example the stray pattern of the fecal
matter on this turret hasn't been
cleaned for a while
Butler may be neglecting his duties
I can only
named after his former lover that he
lost 23 years ago to this day
but need we forget that we also found
some stray hairs that may have been
animal related but I suspect that they
were part of this insidious plot to
murder whoever the hell wears in this
goddamn home we will get to the bottom
of it
I swear that on you Jim and Jim and Jim
back at all and our mother Jim
I'm gonna get a better look
what do you see Jim could it be the
pictures of these victims for me
family members parents it's a portable
yourself remember our cousin Jim Jim you
would often Flay himself alive two sad
movies such as The Passion of the Christ
Jenner some new development Jim
he sees us Jim
we're losing we gotta go get my Uncle
Jim
[Music]